nadine zahawi thank you very much for
being on the programme
this morning some qui pretty concerning
statistics from the royal college of
gps uh white people twice as likely to
be vaccinated as black people
three times more likely than those who
are mixed race
how concerned is the government and why
do you think there is this lower take-up
in some communities
very concerned so if you look at the ons
data
vaccine acceptance in the uk is
incredibly high which is
very positive 85 percent of adult
populations say they will
uh very likely take the vaccine but the
15 percent that are vaccine hesitant
skew heavily towards bame communities
and especially
afro caribbean and black communities and
of course
um uh other asian bame communities so
uh the nhs uh throughout the whole
deployment
program we have a a a a standing
daily equality section that we go
through
and make sure we're targeting both with
the national message
the regional message and then the local
message hyper local message
uh and engaging with those faith leaders
community leaders
we've announced 23 million pounds
working with local government
because local government has a big part
to play in this uh
and um uh eleanor kelly who is the chief
executive of southern council has joined
us as ceo of the
deployment campaign uh and we'll be
saying more on this on how we continue
to make sure that we deliver the
messages in
the languages that people feel
comfortable with as well with
translating all the messages into
13 languages from arabic to farsi to
urdu to
polish across the board so that we reach
those
hard-to-reach communities because as
long as we
uh make sure we reach them those top
four cohorts represent 88
of mortality and as you heard from andy
burnham and i'm glad he agrees on the
jcbi
prioritization for phase one the top
nine cohorts is 99
of mortality if one particular community
remains
unvaccinated then the virus will seek
them out and will go through that
community like wildfire and that's not
something
any of us wish to see which is why we're
spending a lot of time a lot of
resources in this area and you'll hear
more on this from me in the coming days
as well uh really concerning uh
of course and you did say last week
though that the government isn't keeping
a record
of who's refusing to take the vaccine
if you don't keep the data how can you
actually tackle the problem
so so if we uh keep ethnicity data and
we're publishing ethnicity data
we also know what the population is of
the top four cohorts
and then the population of the top nine
cohorts that is known to us but because
this country has boris johnson quite
rightly said you know we don't mandate
vaccination you know we don't make it uh
you know we don't force it
down people's throats we do it by
persuasion by sharing information
by explaining to people how good it is
for them to stay
safe for them personally and their
family and their community
and so we know obviously levels of
uptake and therefore
focus on those groups that we need to
focus on to make sure
we get the heart to reach groups not
just of course what we've had is a
phenomenal response you know 90 percent
of over 75s
have been uh vaccinated with the first
dose
very high levels of acceptance that is
the highest
in the history of vaccination programs
flu vaccines don't even get close to
that
uh figure they're in the sort of high
eighty percent and that's fine
but but as look this is an important
issue we're focusing on it and you will
see
more from us on this uh with the nhs to
make sure we deliver
for all the communities that we want
okay
there are also concerns about
anti-vaccine content online there's a
report out by sky news
today showing that social media
companies are one of the key ways
that new anti-vaxxers if you like um
raise money and get the message out and
do social media companies need to do
more to protect against
anti-vaccine content they're doing
quite a bit but we continue to work with
them so we set up a unit
in the cabinet office a cross-government
unit so they're doing enough then you
think
no no i'm i'm about to answer your
question uh sophie
we set up a unit across government that
uh looks at all the
anti-vaxx messages and alerts the social
media platforms
to them to help take them down as
quickly as possible we want them to do
as much as they can as quickly as they
can
and we continue to work with them very
closely but we can always do more
because there is too much
uh i can tell you from my own community
i look at the middle eastern community
and
uh sort of the conspiracy theories they
don't just use obviously
facebook and twitter they also use uh
other platforms like whatsapp and text
messaging
uh to get those uh anti-vaxx messages
those you know fake videos fake
information across
and we're working with the social media
not just on the platforms but on the uh
other channels that people may use to
try and
uh spread some of this fake information
prey on on those who are worried and who
may be hesitant
which is why we want them to get the
real information from their gps that's a
brilliant piece you've done there
because actually it's the practitioners
i've done it numerous round tables
with black and ethnic minority
practitioners nurses doctors who've been
jabbed themselves because the best
experience is from someone you
trust that's already taken the vaccine
yeah it does feel as if those uh front
line health workers are absolutely vital
and i'm sorry to rush you we've got
quite a lot to get through but um
we've talked a lot about the concerns
over takeout but of course the vaccine
rollout program does seem to be going
pretty well very fast um a letter from a
government advisor this week
said the vast majority of adults will
have received a covered jab by the end
of may so are we on track for that to
happen
well the limiting factor is vaccine
supply so vaccine display remind remains
finite
um i can tell you that yesterday between
11 and 12 o'clock we almost got to a
thousand jabs a minute we got to 979
jabs a minute
so the deployment infrastructure of
which gps are absolutely
uh the backbone of this whole deployment
with hospital hubs
national vaccination centers now we have
100 national vaccination centers
and 200 pharmacies the deployment
infrastructure can do
the volumes that we'll get through i'm
confident we'll meet our mid-february
target of the top four cohorts
i'm also confident because i have enough
line of sight
of the deliveries that are coming
through that will
also meet the one to nine cohorts uh by
uh may and we'll say more about that
next week when we hit the first target i
hope
uh it all goes well it's a tough target
by the way many many people who are
clinically extremely vulnerable uh have
to be reached by the gp some of them
can't travel we have to go to their home
we set up a drive-through in some
tourbillons yesterday and the emotion
there was
extraordinary sophie people who are
clinically extremely vulnerable
shielding
could come in their car and get that
first dose was amazing
lots of people of course are going to be
moving to get their second dose
in the coming weeks um given logistical
challenges given supply challenges that
you
mentioned should we expect the pace to
be slowing down a bit and
could that put the target vaccinating
all over 50s by the end of april at risk
well it will vary no doubt and as i said
look a
vaccine manufacturer remains challenging
any manufacturing process is charged i'm
a chemical engineer by background but
as patrick vanessa said there's never
been a vaccine
manufacturing process of a new vaccine
without its challenges
but we see better stability now and
greater volumes but they will move
around
plus as you quite rightly just pointed
out we are beginning off obviously
to store the second dose vaccine as well
uh so we will begin in march to do both
both
more first dose but of course then the
second dose for both pfizer
and oxford testing obviously uh
important as well
uh government's going to be offering
quick cover tests to all workplaces with
over
50 employees what's the idea when's it
going to happen
so both are important it used to be to
employers who have 250
workers we've reduced that to 50 because
we want it to become the norm
that people when they go to work once we
are over this
obviously lock down then they can be
tested
rapidly we've got the volumes in place
we've done
a similar thing with local government
and key workers this is a really
important point
sophie because vaccines are our way out
of this pandemic but
coupled with vaccines is test trace and
isolate in the way we're doing now in
woking
so we need to be really forensic because
of these new variants
to go after them very rapidly and
isolate them and isolate those
who are then you know who have the new
variant to quarantine so that we can
stamp out any new virus while we
continue to vaccinate the nation
talking about the new variants clearly a
big concern
for the government and everyone really
the financial times has reported
this study of 2 000 people which
has shown the oxford vaccine does seem
to be less effective against the south
african variant
has limited efficacy in protecting
against
mild and moderate disease have you seen
this study and are you worried by it
i spoke to jonathan van tam this morning
uh of course the good news about the
oxford astrozenica vaccine which is sort
of the flip side of that headline you've
just
uh quoted is that it does protect
against severe
uh disease well hang on a minute sorry
it does it it at the minute
i understand that astrazeneca believes
that they're confident that it does
but that actually because the median age
of participants in this trial was 31
the fact that no one died or became
seriously ill they just don't know yet
if it does well as i said through their
own trials
that um it does uh effectively deal with
serious
uh illness serious disease and
hospitalization but to your very good
point and that's this is a really
important point for your viewers
of course the virus will mutate and the
more we vaccinate the more virus will
attempt to survive and mutate
even further we have the world's best
genomic sequencing
ecosystem industry in the uk so we are
able to sequence
uh the genomes of the mutations rapidly
and then talk to the manufacturers
and you saw the deal we announced this
week with cureback where we're going to
be
looking to manufacture the new variant
of vaccine that deals with the variant
of virus
in the uk the same way as the prime
minister visited
scotland to look at valniva where that
vaccine
is a whole inactivated virus so has much
greater
um effectiveness hopefully on
the virus and that again future proofs
our country so that we know we can
produce
new variants of vaccine ready to
revaccinate or boost
uh the protection of the nation this is
this is all part of the strategy
uh that the prime minister quite rightly
pushed us both
in base with the vaccine task force but
also
in our thinking now that we have to not
only vaccinate the nation and protect
them which is what he wants us to do
rapidly
but also begin to think about okay well
what comes next if the
virus mutates we have to be ready with
the new variant of vaccine to deal with
that virus
mutations clearly concern south african
variant clear concern
what i don't really understand is you
know the government's so worried about
the south african variant that you've
told people on certain postcodes to
that it's imperative that they stay at
home so
that means that people who live in
ealing or some postcodes in worcester
for example
are told that they can't even leave
their houses they should get a test as
quickly as possible
but someone can still actually travel
back from south africa as long as they
don't get a
you know direct flight and they don't
even necessarily have to quarantine in a
hotel
how does that work well i'll tell you
exactly so
hotel qualities is part of the overall
um control of our borders um it is one
part an important part and that's coming
on the 15th
of february but actually the really
important part
is the passenger locator form which
allows to know exactly where you're
staying
and of course the pre-departure testing
that we've introduced
and of course we've banned travel from
33 countries where we are worried
uh about the uh the mutations
of the virus in those countries so it is
a combination of all those things so you
you if you come from any country even
now you have to quarantine
for 10 days and of course we will make
sure
that that is policed well and it already
is
uh being policed much more strictly
you're relying on people though aren't
you you're relying on their good will to
do it
well no the hotels is if you are if you
are a british national or a resident of
this country
and you're coming back from those uh
countries of concern the 33 countries
then we will put you in a quarantine
hotel
but if you're coming to the united
kingdom for any other reason you still
have to quarantine and the
the passenger locator for me the airline
will not let you on
if you don't have that filled in and
actually it's an offense not to have it
filled in
and carries a fine with it as well as of
course the pre
uh departure test so it is a combination
of measures countries like tokyo did the
same thing in january
um canada the same thing in january all
countries are looking at how
to protect you're talking um you talk
about the red list of countries and
but the south african variant's been
found in 41 countries
29 of them on on the ban list on the red
list if you like traveling to the uk
the brazilian variant another variant of
concern found in 10 countries
six haven't been added to the red list
if you look at what sage warned on the
21st of january they said that
geographically targeted travel bans
cannot be relied upon to stop the
importation of uvarians so why aren't
you
imposing hotel quarantines for all
travellers
well because one you already have to
quarantine
it doesn't have to be in a hotel we are
saying that anything you know from
harding that happened 20 000 people told
yourself isolate don't do it
yeah every day so so and and well at the
moment
the test and trace is running at about
86
of people who are testing positive
actually being contacted
93 to 96 of their contacts being
contacted
and the capacities are eight hundred
thousand testing my point is people
don't always do what they're told
and that's why there are fines
associated with it and also that this
rapid testing now
so one of the things that we are doing
if you look at what we've done in
worcestershire and in in woking as an
example
is uh the ability to very rapidly put in
the resource to test uh very small
geographies
and we've learned that by the way we've
learned because we've seen it done
in other countries like australia and
elsewhere so it's a combination
of a mass vaccination program plus
forensic rapid testing and 10-day
quarantine
with fines and with testing there and
checking
you you have to quarantine for 10 days
and we will be checking to make sure
that that is happening it's a
combination of all those things
that sage said you have to deliver
because that's how you protect
the country whilst we are vaccinated
sage also said uh
there's no point just targeting certain
countries putting them on the red list
because of indirect travel
but also because of the lag between the
emergence and identification of variants
of concern i mean that's true isn't it i
mean you have to look at the first wave
where
you initially were banning flights from
china but not from places like spain or
parts of italy where lots of people had
the virus but we just didn't know it at
the time but we're not
learning the lessons of the first wave
here well i i disagree with respect
because you just heard
uh david navarro talk about us learning
uh the lessons we learned the lessons
around uh
sage in terms of making sure that
we target very very quickly which is
what we're doing now which is what we're
doing in woking now one of our strengths
is the ability to sequence uh the
variants rapidly in the uk
and we're offering that to the uk which
is to your question
if you're able to
i
yes i can excellent um just finally um
i just want to ask you a little bit
about vaccine passports we've seen
countries like denmark and sweden say
they're looking at introducing these
vaccine passports if you have a vaccine
you can travel into the country are we
looking at the possibility
of creating them here no we're not
we have as of yesterday uh given the
first dose to 11.5 million
people and what they get is a card from
their nhs
with their name on it and of course uh
the date they've been have
they've been vaccinated with the first
dose and then the date for their second
dose
one we don't know the impact of the
vaccines on transmission
two it would be discriminatory and i
think the right thing to do
is to you know make sure that people
come forward be vaccinated
because they want to rather than it
being made in some way mandatory
uh through a passport uh or others if
other countries obviously
require uh some form of of proof
then you can ask your gp because your gp
will hold the record
and of course uh that will then be uh
vaccine
but we are not planning to have a
passport in the uk i just want to repeat
that because i've had a lot of it
on my social media uh there are
yeah small startup technology companies
that have had some funding from ukri and
innovate uk
who are looking at apps in this area but
we are certainly
not looking to introduce as part of the
vaccine deployment program
just quickly because i know how
important this is for so many of our
viewers in the lockdown
um we've talked a lot about how well
they've warned of a fourth wave
if restrictions are eased too quickly
are there reports today that nhs
providers wants to wait till infections
have fallen
95 on current levels before easing
restrictions
how long should we be bracing ourselves
for for these restrictions to keep going
for
well our target is obviously to have
given the first stage to the top
four um most vulnerable cohorts by
mid-february so that's the 15th of
february when we will look
and review all the data we've got a
couple of big pieces of research
one in care homes testing every day one
with frontline healthcare workers
testing every day
which will give us much better data in
terms of the impact of the vaccine
on infections and transmission the prime
minister will then come to parliament on
the 22nd of february as he's quite
rightly
uh you know agreed and has targeted
and then talk about how we're going to
gradually first of all reopen schools on
the 8th of march if all goes well
and then gradually reopen the whole of
our economy
but we have to be obviously mindful that
we want to make it
based on the evidence of the vaccine
efficacy
and the impact obviously on transmission
hospitalization
and death ultimately it's a race against
death sophie that i keep
reminding anyone who's willing to listen
to me and which is why we're moving so
rapidly to
vaccine protect those most vulnerable
cohorts the one to nine is 99 of death
from covert